please give a warm welcome to my good
friend bill burr everybody cheer here
yeah I know yeah what's your show you're
tall yeah I know I got an average but we
seem like the same like look in the
monitor that's about right
I look uncomfortable actually that was
an internet comment I saw that was like
they said when I see people in high
chairs pretending to have like a casual
conversation and never addressing the
fact that they're in these book you
gotta dish there should be a high top
bar here with like potato skins sorry
hurry
Applebee's going out of business which
is kind of perfect cuz I feel like an
Applebee's waiter don't I just like
flaming fajitas does that feel
yeah you have like that like I don't
know if it's if it's me but you you're
so happy sometimes it bothers me it's
like all right I get it
the sun is shining just take it down a
little bit like I I get actually anxiety
around people as happy as you it's like
I can't I can't hit the ball back when I
can't like I can't sustain it's a rally
you go into the net with the heaviness
I'm just like this is over it's gonna
smash it right at me the happy ball yeah
you're a happy fall you come off as
agitated but you know oh yeah I'm
affable you know I like a vote people
have a tendency is that they would they
will watch your act and then they just
think like oh he's like that 24/7
screaming and yelling and that that's
not true
I mean it is definitely a chunk of my
day oh no I don't like being you know
angry I don't want to be that guy I'd
like to be jolly but uh it hasn't been
in the cards
I try to be you know what you do you do
your podcast which is just you really
just kind of letting it out and you let
it out in your standup
but then doesn't that contribute to you
being like a pretty well-balanced fellow
the rest of this on yeah it's the second
I eat it in I don't know what that is I
I can't speak for other people but I
definitely I love doing the podcast and
I definitely love venting and when
people laugh at will you find annoying
and you get that that laugh that is
beyond them laughing they're like
getting it yeah like yes yes exactly
that that definitely you know brings it
down a little bit absolutely